is there anything you wrote in the
earlier books that you feel back to into
a narrative corner there certainly I'm
ed that's overstating it I mean there
are certainly mistakes in the earlier
books that you know there's that
transsexual horse I mentioned then there
are some eyes to change color these are
these are simple mistakes but they
irritate me because I don't want to make
any mistakes and also because there are
in the books deliberate inconsistencies
where I'm using the device of the
unreliable narrator or using a point of
view structure that they wear to people
remember something that happened in very
different ways and then may not be
remembering it accurately and because
the other is other mistakes some of my
readers tend to assume that those things
are also mistakes when they're not you
know they're me being very clever
so that's irritating there's there's the
there are again it these are all
relatively minor things I wouldn't say
they backed me into a corner
well introduction of Tyrion where he
does like a simple salt over offered
door frame and and lands on his feet the
first time he meets Jon Snow was
probably something I could have left out
I've kind of explained it later and done
a pretty good job of it I think but it
still might have been better just
omitted also in that same that same
chapter where they're having a feast at
Winterfell and the Kings party is there
and and all that is from Jon's viewpoint
I believe is the viewpoint character in
that scene and bran is not
shouldn't when everybody goes marching
forth and so forth and numerous fans
have written me letters about you know
the deep meaning of why bran is omitted
and it's just I sort of forgot about
bran when I was writing that chapter I
just stay was there I just happened it
in John wasn't glancing in his direction
and didn't mention him that thing so
that's the kind of stuff that you know
gets by you but I don't think it's
backing you into the corners oh yeah I
made a little misstep there I stubbed my
toe